foreign
[Music]
happy love to say to all of you yes 7B
is celebrated as a World's laughter day
and why not after all instead that
laughter is the best medicine but why so
because laughter releases a hormone
named us and darwini and this endorphin
is the same hormone which is also
commonly known as the feel good for hope
this hormone helps us to reduce stress
anxiety depression as well as to release
the physical pain well laughter also
helps in the increase of production of
growth hormone which is very crucial for
our health and the strength of our body
not only that laughter can surely
increase your communication skills
social skills isn't it so go ahead laugh
it loud and be a reason for somebody's
happiness happy love Thursday everyone